not not a bad turnout uh result i think
was uh
rather interesting um
mark wrote this on 17
just under 17 000 uh conservatives
vote share sort of down to under 14 000
labor more than halving but i mean i
mean that is a story we shouldn't
underplay 349 votes absolutely abysmal
they had eight thousand votes before and
the greens do really quite well too so
insurgent parties doing rather well uh
majority there of what just under 3 000
so perhaps smaller than someone expected
well yeah you know by the standards of
what douglas carlson and claxton it is
quite small but 3000 is is not bad but
yes ukip were a bit nervous yesterday at
some at some points and it wasn't quite
where the polls said it was going to be
um let's see what the you know the shift
in the shared with the share of the vote
was so it leaves you with ukip on 42
percent the conservatives on 35 labour
on 17
that awful lib dem vote show under one
percent not even making it to one
absolutely extraordinary isn't it and
the question for me is uh is where some
of this well firstly the conservatives
they would say we held up all right
there went from 50 to 35
not bad that is the result of the
kitchen sink strategy the prime minister
visiting several times several times
lots of money lots of you know hundreds
of activists so they kept respectable
and they'll feel that they can attack
back in the general election labour you
know they held this seat in 2010 just
four years ago so you know i'd say that
that wasn't very good but they're sort
of playing it all down saying in a
by-election you get a different dynamic
of course but you look at the change in
the share of the vote that kind of
really tells you what was going on
behind the scenes it does tell you a
story and it shows you i would say a
plague on all your houses all the
mainstream parties uh doing badly
clearly uh the cons them gaining from
the conservatives but but gaining from
labor and the liberal democrats doing
abysmally two
um
but you know what we showed in the
package before which is that gaining
from labour too in certain parts of this
constituency and of course 168 days now
until the general election 168 days for
all these parties to pour over these
results what does this all mean for ukip
in terms of seats because of course
they'd identified 25 seats 12 of those
in particular they're targeting so what
natural fraud told me was that they were
using the data they've gathered to hone
their suit strategy this is what we have
say i mean they've targeted 25 seats
more generally and then they hone that
down to 12 you see you know a
lot in in kent north planet south valley
sitting born in sheppy thorac
a labor seat up there in great grimsby
but these are the seats they say they
think they've got a good chance and of
course our sky analysts have identified
six in particular yep
these are the ones that michael thrasher
feels are of particular uh you know that
they really have got quite a good chance
in uh the ones i'd really highly
highlight are is this one southallied
that's where nigel is cool they're
standing margate that area the key
question of course is are we going to
see a sea of purple come election day
what's your prediction here um i don't
want to see a sea of turks
i think that they've got a chance in
those seats where they can take both
from red and from blue simultaneously
where they can do that they've got a
chance uh because that's what they've
shown so it would uh you know both main
parties were losers today uh and that
will encourage ukip but they are going
to really hyper target where they think
that they can win and they're using this
data to hone that strategy interesting
six months faisal thank you